Alright, let's make this a little bit more challenging. I'm going to show you
some shaded images. And then I want you to write the missing parts of the
fraction. So for example, I know this image has 3/4, or 3 out of 4 pieces
shaded. This other image has one, two, three, four, five, six out of 8 pieces
shaded. I know that these two fractions are actually equal. I want to think
about moving this piece here over into this empty region here, and then my
figures would match. And really what I did is I doubled the number of shaded
pieces I have. I split up each piece into two parts. Also, I doubled every piece
As I have, because in total I have eight new pieces here so I multiply the total
number of pieces 4 by 2 to get 8